Oh
yes well if it is an optimal optimus you
will not stop the Predacons this time no
your reign of terror is over Megatron
Optimus Primal maximize oh hey I was
just uh I'll just cut to the graphic
like a lot of kids I grew up with Beast
Wars
these were my transformers debuting in
1996 beast wars transformers took the
popular property to a whole different
level instead of vehicle these
characters transformed into animals
instead of Autobots and Decepticons we
got maximals and predacons the show
takes place in the distant future of the
original transformers run but through a
spacetime phenomenon these robots in
disguise actually end up on earth
millions of years in the past it's a
very early all computer animated series
along with that unique look Beast Wars
has become a favorite of a lot of fans
all over the world the characters
setting and storylines helps this show
stand the test of time plus those toys
are the coolest thing ever these are the
top 5 best episodes of
number five feral scream parts one and
two from season three this two-parter
had a lot going on in it along with the
return of another Dino by clone we're
introduced at transmittal to and get
cheaters best character development in
the series Optimus Primal and cheetah
are tracking Waspinator on a mission to
deliver a stasis pod to Megatron who
plans to recreate the lost Dino bots as
a subservient hunter the operation is a
success and Dino bots is reborn as a
transmittal - during the scuffle cheater
is damaged when getting caught in the
electrical field which helps create this
new version of Dino bots he's plagued by
nightmares but will neither enter the CR
chamber for repair nor submit to a
medical exam ttours troubles only get
worse as he slowly realizes his whole
form is changing feral scream
encapsulated a lot of what fans liked
about the show we get great character
moments for cheetah or while seeing a
new form for the Transformers along with
some badass scenes featuring the new
versions of cheetor and Dinobots we
still get a bit of the goofy humor that
the show was known for installs the
transmetal try
[Music]
while transmittal to Dinobot was a fun
twist to throw in as the series began to
charge towards the finish line
cheaters metamorphosis is handled really
well and is the main reason why this
made it into the top 5
it's a slow change that hasn't
questioning his sanity and we get some
great sequences from
[Music]
cheaters new attitude was fun to see
come forth as he changed from an
overeager kid to a more confident
maximal with an awesome new look I never
got a transmittal to Dinobot or cheat or
toy but I really wish I would
let's maximize into number four number
four the agenda parts one through three
from season two as a kid watching this
show the agenda was one of the most
amazing things I've ever seen on TV up
to that point the finale of season 2 was
nothing less than thrilling in part one
the tripe rheticus council sends in a
special agent to prehistoric earth to
deal with Megatron this turns out to be
the former Decepticon ravage rebuilt as
a Predacon forming an unlikely alliance
with the maximals ravage arrests and
detained Megatron while this is all
happening the deadly attraction between
the noble maximal silver bolt and
cunning Predacons black Arachnia heaps
up in a way that has them both going
against their orders to be with each
other in part 3 we see what Megatron's
plan was all along destroy the Autobots
lying dormant in the Ark millions of
years before they are to awaken in 1984
thus destroying the current timeline and
the Autobots victory over the
Decepticons Optimus and the maximals
must stop this from happening at all
cost so much was happening over all
three parts of the agenda it's a credit
to the show that things never got too
confusing it balanced a few different
ongoing storylines very well and in my
opinion this is the series at its
strongest the string of episodes from
the end of season 2 through the
beginning of season 3 solidified Beast
Wars as something special I loved seeing
the callbacks to the original
Transformers series and I wasn't even
that familiar with it at that age I'm
sure it was even more exciting for fans
that lived through that first run
this is Megatron leader of the
Decepticons and if you are hearing this
it means that failed
Decepticons forever in addition to a few
interesting side plots Megatron's plan
to kill the Autobots Optimus Prime and
alter the timeline itself was such a
great idea it created massive tension
and could actually affect what had come
before in transformers 4 the Cybertron
that is rightfully ours I unleashed the
call of vengeance
well
[Music]
I think if you're a fan of the autobots
and decepticons but never watched Beast
Wars these episodes should pull you in
check them out for a great story
number three optimal situation from
season three the premiere of the final
season of the show picks up right where
the agenda left off the maximals are
unconscious as the time stream begins to
unravel a direct result of megatron
attacking the original Optimus Prime in
his dormant state Optimus Primal
attempts to merge Prime's spark into his
own keeping it safe while rhinox
performs surgery but the extra soul is
too much for primal to handle and his
body undergoes a startling
transformation love this the conclusion
of this story and kickoff of season 3
featured some incredible moments the
main one being Optimus Primal changing
into optimal optimus after absorbing
prime spark to keep it safe while rhinox
attempts to save the Autobot leader but
how do you feel
in a word drive with his new body
Optimus leads the maximal to fight off
Megatron forces however protecting prime
spark leads to a disaster
[Music]
when he finally returns that spark to
its rightful owner
prime and primal share a brief important
moment
[Music]
that's terrorized into number two number
two code of hero from season two I know
a lot of people might be upset that this
is at number two instead of number one
it's definitely the most famous episode
of the show and it is absolutely amazing
using his presence on prehistoric earth
strategically Megatron employs the
golden disc to pinpoint how he will
change the future to rewrite the
timeline and ensure Predacon rule
Dinobot learns of this and gives his all
to stop the Predacons from incinerating
the valley from which humans are
destined to evolve this episode is
packed to the brim with emotion for a
character that we all came to love after
recently turning on the maximal to join
the Predacons
Dinobot has rejoined the good guys but
he's having a hard time forgiving
himself for that trespass Rattrap adds
to this you know what I used to figure I
had you pegged oh yeah he's a slag
spouting saurian but at least you know
where he stands guess we live in Lane
Dinobot ends up alone defending the
proto humans from an all-out attack by
Megatron and the Predacons that change
the future it is here where this episode
show I now find I have no choice at all
I am a warrior next exactly chai Dinobot
falls to it injuries but before doing so
save the valley and the future it's a
bittersweet moment that elevates the
show on a touching level you saved the
lives of those who live here now those
who are still to come
apparently this affected rattraps so
much that he goes back to his pre
transmittal form
it's a remarkable episode and a moving
farewell to Dinobot
the greatest of cybertron there were a
lot of really strong episodes of beast
wars over its three season run so before
we get to number one here are more than
a few honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best Beast Wars
episode is transmutate from season 2 I
didn't make this decision lightly I
rewatched this and coded hero an extra
time before making the final call
transmutate just barely squeaks out the
victory for me silver bolt and rat trap
discover another stasis pod but this one
contains a strange malformed transformer
unable to speak clearly and lacking the
specs of a scientist or warrior the
transmutate is both puzzled and puzzling
silver bolt seeds in this simple machine
a kindred spirit
an innocent Predacon rampage sees
something as well another one of a kind
freak as alone as he is why I had this
episode at number one is because of its
strong message delivery and sentiment
that was rare for the series in one
episode I cared about transmutate almost
as much as some of the more popular
characters in the show sympathy can be a
very strong storytelling element when
presented in the right way
I think they nailed that part of the
pathos here and made a unique episode
that stands out from the pack beasts
load
[Music]
[Applause]
it cannot even transform this thing is
useless get rid of it
know how transmutate effects silver bolt
and rampage is another reason why this
story is so strong rampage cares about
no one but himself he's not even a
voluntary prentke but in the fection for
transmutate and herbs to protect him
questions character out in a way we
never saw again
come with me calm
I will protect you I'm not afraid
silverbolt defends the deformed
transformer when the maximals aren't
sure what to do with him his passion
here made me like him even more best
thing for us all the beat it didn't
stasis luck immediately are we Predacons
now do we destroy whatever does not fit
our definition of perfection it's a
powerful message and one I think we can
all learn from when a show called Beast
Wars makes you think in this way it's
got to be doing something right that's
why it's my number one the double
experience of watching the show and
owning the toys made Beast Wars
something special in the mid to late 90s
former show and toy line to thank for
that there was a sequel series called
Beast Machines which ran for two seasons
after wars ended however I just couldn't
get into it for whatever reason what's
your opinion on beast machine is it
worth going back to watch I want to hear
what you guys think what is your
favorite beast wars episode what do you
want me to cover next in the show leave
a comment and let me know now - the big
announcement in two weeks on July 4th in
honor of the 10 year anniversary of its
first upload we will be doing a top 5
best nostalgia critic episode the twist
is you will be choosing all five spots
that's right we have a link in the
description for you to vote for your
favorite nc episode follow the
instructions and make sure you spread
the word
each episode chosen will be talked about
by the man himself Doug Walker and some
of the cast and crew that were involved
you have until Monday June 26 at 11:59
p.m. make sure you get your voice heard
for more content subscribe to my
personal channel youtube.com slash
awesome walther like my new Facebook
page facebook.com slash awesome Walter B
and follow me on Twitter to take part in
more polls about what may be covered in
the future come back next week as we
keep it transformers kind of you'll see
[Music]